oui je m'entends bien alors je pense que
oui mais les autres ne n'y crois pas les
producteurs pensent que le romancier
doit surtout pas se mêler l'adaptation
de son livre
et pourtant de mon point de vue si l'on
sait écrire des scénarios sont deux
métiers différents
on est le mieux placé pour se trahir qui
est la définition pour moi de
l'adaptation c'est une trahison
nécessaire il se trouve que là j'avais
prévu d'écrire ce livre
retour à cuba pendant les 6 ou 10 mois
qui l'ont été ceux de nos différents
confinement donc j'ai envie de dire un
peu cyniquement c'est bien tombé pour
moi je trouve que le confinement
sinon incite plutôt à la paresse d'un
écrivain c'est quelqu'un qui est
toujours un peu confiné l'écriture c'est
à la fois un mélange curieux entre le
confinement et l'évasion par
l'imaginaire
[Musique]
je pense que les livres qui sont sorti
au printemps dernier ont également
souffert lorsque les librairies étaient
fermés je vous avoue est là mon livre
est sorti en janvier je craignais
énormément conçoit nouveau confiné donc
je suis heureux de ce ne sont pas le cas
les gens lisent ils redécouvrent au
moins mais malheureusement je pense que
si on faisait un sondage on se rendrait
compte qu'il y en a beaucoup plus qui se
sont réfugiés sur netflix que dans les
pages des livres papier allez vous le
voyez tout le temps vous voyez dans des
librairies donc au fond un bon titre
c'est celui que vous assumez toujours
cinq ans dix ans après c'est pas
forcément celui que l'éditeur ou celui
que vos proches vous ont conseillé de
garder ça dépend des 10 romans retour à
cuba je les trouvais après j'ai
travaillé pendant deux ans l'écriture de
ce roman avec un autre titre il les lit
vivent avec leur propre vie et il était
parti sur une autre direction donc le
titre que j'avais choisie n'était pas le
bon pour mon roman précédent le mari les
harpistes que le titre précédait et il
est resté jusqu'au bout
donc c'est vraiment pas il n'y a pas de
cas d'école ça dépend à chaque fois un
livre que l'on écrit qu'on pense
[Musique]
parce que dans moby dick il y as pour
moi tout ce que j'aime dans la
littérature c'est à dire un style
incroyable je recommande à tous ceux qui
n'ont pas lu herman melville de lire ses
livres
c'est un écrivain funambule des mots
styliste il parfait il y a une pensée
très profond d'une véritable
métaphysique une métaphore de l'océan
dont les profondeurs contiennent tous
les dangers comme peut-être notre
inconscient par exemple et enfin une
véritable aventure c'est une histoire
démentant terme de rebondissements de
situation pour moi c'est un des livres
parfait
[Musique]